how about that border oh yeah oh my god
let's let's let's talk about uh what's
going on sorry I want to preface this
I'm generally an open borders kind of
dude like I really think that there
should be the getting into the US should
be a lot easier there should be there
shouldn't be uh the waiting list and
stuff like that it should be easier
I do think the U.S has the right to to
say we're going to accept these people
and or accept this person and not accept
this person
um but what's going on at the border
that's that's a lot of people that are
in a precarious situation living under a
bridge like that's rough so oh and more
more Caravans have shown up yeah so uh
yeah the the guys from Fox down there
are putting up more and more videos
they're just people just walking in tens
of thousands showed up in rionosa 200
plus miles away going to McAllen is is
the is the biggest part of that story or
this story is it the people coming uh to
the border that are you know being
essentially just disregarded by the the
federal government or is it the federal
government's response is it the FAA
saying that you can't have drones in the
air and yeah and the fact that that he
reversed it though Kamala Harris talked
about being in charge of the board and
has has not been down there to look at
this at all uh I I really feel like as
much as I feel for the people that are
at the border and stuff I feel like the
big part of the story is the
administration's lack of a response
unpreparedness
um and I mean honestly ineptitude
ineptitude is even the right word
because they know there's a problem and
they're not doing anything about it now
you've got this video of these uh these
border patrol guys on Horseback and one
guy was apparently like whipping one of
the it was a lasso it was Alaska I
thought I thought it was I thought it
was actually trying to laugh that's
crazier it's crazy but it's better than
whipping oh for sure
in Russia you cross our border they
shoot you or North Korea I'm not saying
we should shoot these people but you
have to understand the third world's
collapsing it they already broke
Europe's borders the very same U.N group
that's what's directing this and it's
beyond uh just uh scientific neglect on
purpose your five sentences in and we're
we're edging real close to Illuminati
you start talking about the EU and I
know where you're heading I know where
you're heading I'm giving you all the
real knowledge here is what happened
Biden in March early March of 2000 said
if I win the election immediately surged
the border and then now they've
basically been letting everybody in they
say they have flights deported people
it's barely happening they're letting in
unaccompanied men they're letting
criminals he didn't say that verbatim
like what is exact words he said if he
said he said he said when I win the
election
all of you that want to come to the
United States as as refugees immediately
surge the Border just type in Biden
Biden called for migrants to immediately
surge the Border there's a video it was
in the debate with Trump and he also had
a press conference and said it again
yeah but Kamala said don't come and then
they meme the crap out of it that was
after that it was also a Chicago Tribune
article about it it's important to look
at
the response that is important because
we're Americans we have control we have
some sense semblance of control but also
the just the fact that economic when
economics start to falter you're going
to see Mass surges of immigration
migration which is extremely dangerous
for a species so we got to look at it
systemically let's uh let's fact check
you Alex he thinks he can come on this
show and start spouting these things as
if we can't fact check the guy okay Alex
how about this from the Chicago Tribune
Biden called for the Border surge
I got the audio right here I know I have
it
here we go we got some oh here we go
look at this
well it's out of cut it's out of context
but he's talking about the southern
border no that's what you're saying it's
not oh
let me just read the quotes yes so I I
Google searched it Chicago Tribune Ramos
are you prepared to say tonight that you
and President Barack Obama made a
mistake on deportations why should
Latinos trust you Biden answered
criticizing Donald Trump's handling of
migrants saying quote I would in fact
make sure that there is that we
immediately surge to the Border all
those people people see are seeking
Asylum they deserve to be heard that's
who we are we're a nation that says if
you want to flee and your fleeing
oppression you should come flee they did
and the article goes on and come they
did surging some came wearing Biden
t-shirts reading Biden please let us in
you know again it's one thing if you're
a real Refugee they just call everybody
that gets there legal I've had my team
down there and I've been down there
three times this year my team's been
down there like 10 times at least and
we're going back I mean it is literally
Road Warrior I mean it is crazy town and
let me tell you the board Patrol gets
shot at they get attacked and they get
told okay at least stop people and put
them under this bridge or over here and
so yeah how do you stop people when
you're in swamps and weeds and they're
running through with a bag on their back
you're supposed to stop them and so the
guy's got a lasso that's a desert down
there that's not a swamp uh what's the
real Grand River it's it's it's it's I
promise
it's like a 300 mile border with Mexico
and by the time you get out west it's
totally Big Ben's beautiful it looks
like a spaghetti western but that's our
big it's like California has a valley
it's called the valley and it's a lot of
its Big Trees swamps Rivers uh onions
onions strawberries uh potatoes are
grown down there that was just so Random
Big Trees swamps onions potatoes
onions are awesome uh grapes uh Citrus
lemons limes grapefruit I mean it's
Farmland it's the third largest Citrus
producer in North America so you got
Florida and California California then
Florida then third largest is the is the
Rio Grande Valley you know you know what
I think we're gonna do here I think
we're gonna check a Rio Grande Valley
third largest Citrus producer in the
United States we're gonna we're gonna
put on a couple onions in a pot every
day just to get those caramelized onions
just throughout the day you know they do
that at diners yeah I think we should do
that no but seriously I'm gonna be quiet
for five minutes time
yeah Texas is the third largest producer
of citrus yes it's Texas
the majority of which is growing the Rio
Grande Valley yeah
Alex it's Texas they say that Texas is
the third largest producer of citrus
majority of which is grown in the Rio
Grande Valley what's what's that stuff
you take to fall asleep melatonin can
you guys get Alex a melatonin I told you
we're the third largest producer I get
what he thinks everybody thinks what
they think they think it's a desert half
of it's a desert no no no I'm just
saying that you're like I think you're
already caffeinated but see they think
I'm making this up I'm not you know as
I'm saying it's reality is way crazier
people know that's yeah I I yes and no I
think reality is fairly routine and I
think people want to believe they live
in a magic like there's fantasy there's
an adventure there's a there's a dragon
they got a sleigh and in reality it's
like you wake up you tend to see your
chickens and your tomatoes and you eat
them I agree that the farmer way is the
purest way but then Farmers have to get
together go to war because the goblin
forces sometimes go over the hill and
attack you and that's why we have
freeworldnews.tv I've noticed this
phenomenon when people get super rich
like billions and then they start to
like get rudderless like what what else
is there to do and then their minds
start to wander and I hear like very
very wealthy people get into the occult
because of this like they're just like
they look for like out there like oh
it's real so I don't put anything past
what's crazy
can we just not deviate off of I'd like
the facts we're talking about with
borders and the Republic and the
strength of the union and uh so anyway
so I feel like sometimes I feel that
sometimes people get rich they start to
wonder about like what what is there to
do and then they become grandiose
megalomaniacs who think they can use
their money like Jeff Bezos divorced his
wife Mackenzie Bezos puts billions of
dollars into critical race Theory and
other insane ideologies well that's to
create Division and enslave us I mean
that whole Act is oh we're liberal we
love you but then they take their money
offshore and basically pay almost no
taxes but then they fund critical race
Theory because they're hiding behind
black people if you see all the many
corporate sponsors now it's black people
but oh I want to be nice to black people
no that's a big giant ruthless
Corporation behind that
actually I saw I don't know if you guys
saw that black lives matter was actually
going to protest that store where the
host has gotten to a fight with those
with those black women so did they did
they you said they're going to or do
they they intend to protest are they
going yeah so Hank Newsom he's the black
lives matter guy in New York announced
they're going to be protesting this uh
was it called Carmen's or something yes
so basically there were five women I
think they were all black women and they
tried to go into a restaurant the
hostess apparently told them their
vaccine cards were not real now I
believe that Hostess was probably wrong
and I believe she was being arrested I
genuinely think this because if their
vaccine cards really were fake don't you
think after the fight the cops would
have checked and been like whoa forgery
cards you're under arrest they didn't do
that here's what I think you see that
viral video of the black family and
they're getting checked by the job New
York it's terrible because they because
they don't have the vaccine card but he
points out while he's filming he's like
all these other people you didn't ask
any of them for their vax cards I
believe it because they keep saying in
New York that uh uh the black community
is the least likely to be vaccinated
Tuskegee they don't trust the government
but regardless of that they keep saying
in the press the black community are the
least likely to be vaccinated so what
happens racial profiling you're right
there's this restaurant and some black
women show up they say here's our Vex
cards and the lady says no that's fake
you can't come in because they've
already basically demonized I agree I
think black folks are very very smart
not to trust uh medical tyranny when
something's being forced on you I think
their instincts are right no but these
are women who were vaccinated I
understand and the restaurant like I was
talking about that was about the black
family well they cited a religious
exemption yeah but but uh oh by the way
have you heard now uh Biden is talking
about they will decide what's a
religious exemption and not Congress
shall make no law respecting the
establishment of religion or prohibit
the free exercise thereof but that's the
first amendment no I'm sorry Biden is
The Sovereign he decrees and it is so
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time